foreign
[Music]
foreign
dossier
ladies and gentlemen
our last european council meeting was a
very intensive run
where we tackled many of the current
pressing challenges
first we addressed the current spike in
energy prices and its impact on families
and businesses in particular it affects
vulnerable citizens and smes that are
striving to recover from the pandemic
the european council will count the
toolbox presented by the commission on
short-term relief measures
member states and the commission
are invited to make the best use
possible of this toolbox
we also invited the commission to study
the functioning of the gas and
electricity markets and the eu ets
markets with the help of the european
agency for the cooperation of energy
regulators and the european securities
and market authority
both agencies have in the meantime given
preliminary analysis ahead of the
european council in december
in any case
this price hike shows that we need an
energy market that contributes to
affordable prices that's resilient and
provides predictability and security of
supply and support the transition to
climate neutrality
in this regard we are also looking
forward to the commission's upcoming
proposals or the straightening of the
jazz market
we also invited the european investment
bank to speed up investment in energy
transition
one point was made clear by many leaders
the current price problem is not a
reason to relax our climate ambitions on
the contrary it shows how much this
transition is urgent existential and
necessary the european council will come
back to this important issue in december
on topic 19
we see
case is rising so we must remain
extremely vigilant
our internal coordination is once again
needed and crucial
in order to ensure that measures are as
current as possible
vaccination campaigns are moving in the
right direction but
we must make a final push by overcoming
vaccine hesitancy and tackling this
information
we must remain committed to
international solidarity because the
only way to ensure our safety is to make
sure that everyone else in the world is
safe
through the global rollout of vaccines
ladies and gentlemen we had also a
strategic debate on trade
and the european council agrees
that trade is a powerful instrument that
brings job creation and growth
we must use trade to support our
prosperity
and to promote our social and
environmental priorities as well as our
fundamental values and i know this is a
concern your assembly shares and
together we must clarify our goals and
set clear priorities we want to build a
level playing field we want greater
reciprocity we want to protect our
planet and promote our values and we
need to improve the process
that means greater transparency from
mandate to ratification and this will
help this would help ensure public and
parliamentary support
i think our alberta negotiation for
instance could serve as an inspiring
model
[Music]
the revolution digital zombie
partner
ladies and gentlemen dear colleagues
as you know we also had a debate on the
rule of law
it was the occasion to identify the
exact difficulties and better understand
different points of view
how debate took place in a respectful
atmosphere
the rule of law including the
independence of the judiciary is
fundamental
and on the existing disputes legal and
institutional instruments have already
been activated
and others could still be triggered
but leaders also agreed that the
political dialect needs to continue in
order to find common solutions
dialogue and respect are also necessary
and we know that sometimes rhetoric can
make things more difficult i hope our
debate within the european council
facilitated our common understanding and
was a step i hope a positive step that
should help that would help lead to
solutions
we also had a right-wing distinction on
migration this is always a difficult
issue
but it's imperative to
tackle this important challenge
we are determined to fully control our
external borders to prevent illegal
migration to prevent the loss of life to
prevent the exploitation of migrants by
smugglers
and we will not accept the distress of
human beings of migrants to be used for
political purposes we condemn such
hybrid attacks at the eu borders
and we had also the opportunity to
discuss the implementation and follow-up
of the conclusions of our june meeting
the aim is to strengthen the external
dimension of migration and this includes
intensifying mutually beneficial
partnerships and cooperation with third
countries
the commission has prepared action plans
for key countries and now it's important
to implement them as soon as possible
we also discussed the internal dimension
the migration part is on the table for
many months and we know there are
different positions
this remained very sensitive but we felt
a renewed sense that worked on this must
be taken forward
now
their colleagues
a few words on the situation at the
belarus border
i visited poland on the 10th of november
and i expressed the union's full
solidarity with poland lithuania and
latvia
this is not only an attack on their
borders
this an arabic attack
on our common european borders and we
condemn this attack we will not allow
the belarus regime to intimidate us and
to undermine
our values and our unity
since our european council meeting
events have continued to unfold
so what have we done to address this
crisis which is also a humanitarian
crisis
first the foreign affairs council
adopted an expanded legal basis for
sanctions to include additional sectors
one example the majority of the fleets
of belavia are aircraft leased from eu
companies
this will be halted when the decision is
taken which is imminent
second point we have also taken concrete
action to stop airline companies from
carrying migrants to minsk my own
diplomatic team had productive tools for
example with the turkish authorities but
also with other countries such as the
emirates or uzbekistan or others
and as a result of our joint efforts to
deal with the commission
turkish airlines has decided to stop
allowing bellavia to effectively funnel
migrants to minsk they've also stopped
issuing one-way tickets to means from
istanbul to the key nationalities
concerns
other companies have taken similar
decisions and committee commission
vice president stenas has traveled to a
number of countries in the region
iraq amir's turkey lebanon he has
successfully obtained their cooperation
i comment his work
i met also during my visit in poland
with prime minister moravi to assess the
situation to discuss how poland and eu
can best cooperate and get all so many
to interact with the other eu leaders in
the region the german chancellor has
also called mr putin and celebration
tries to help address the humanitarian
crisis
the belarusian authorities have since
adopted a few measures
that seem to be more positive but
it's too early to assess
whether this will mark a real change in
their position that's why we must remain
cautious yet some of the most vulnerable
migrants have been accommodated in the
warehouse and belarus as cooperatives
with iraq allowing them to organize a
repatriation flight of 700 iraqis we
welcome the cooperation with the
international organization for migration
and unhcr
we call on belarus to provide both
organizations with full access to
provide humanitarian assistance and to
help organize voluntary returns to the
countries of origin
my assessment
is twofold
[Music]
the president
[Music]
another topic of the european council
was the evolving situation of our border
in belarus
a particularly cruel form of hybrid
threat has emerged
with a state-sponsored
instrumentalization of people for
political ends
this is not a bilateral issue
of poland latvian lithuania with belarus
it is the european union as a whole that
is being challenged
this has been initiated and organized by
the lukashenko regime and its supporters
luring people to the border
with the cooperation of migrant
smugglers and criminal networks
when the crisis escalated round about
two weeks ago i was visiting the united
states and the white house and of course
the outrageous behavior of the
belarusian regime
was at the focus of my discussions with
president biden
we both agreed that this is not a
migration crisis
this is the attempt of an authoritarian
regime to try to destabilize its
democratic neighbors a regime that held
fraudulent elections
a regime that violently represses its
own people
a regime that we do not recognize
and the cynical black male
has had just the opposite effect
the whole of europe stands united in
solidarity with lithuania poland and
latvia on this issue
and europe is acting
at exceptional speed on four tracks
humanitarian support
diplomatic outreach to the countries of
origin
sanctions against people and entities in
belarus and sanctions against transport
operators facilitating human trafficking
and smuggling and protection of the
border
first on humanitarian support
what the lukashenka regime is doing
is
exploiting human beings
by taking advantage of their suffering
and provoking violence and loss of life
for political purposes
these people are trapped on belarusian
territory territory because of the
recklessness of the lukashenko regime
and these people need help
and this is why we immediately got in
touch with the un agencies iom and unhcr
we have set up a contact group with them
were in constant contact and we
immediately mobilized funding to support
their efforts on the ground
second on our diplomatic outreach
here too i discussed with president
biden to align our efforts
so we agreed that to counter this
behavior
it is important to coordinate our
sanctions
and to work with the countries of origin
and to work with the airlines that are
transporting migrants to minsk that is
what we have done
and that is what we are doing
we are in the process of coordinating
our sanctions with the united states
canada and the united kingdom
i immediately tasked vice president
zkinas
to engage with the key countries
he has been to iraq to the united arab
united arab emirates to lebanon to
turkey and he will go soon to uzbekistan
hrvp borrel convened the foreign affairs
council to expand the sanctions regime
and commissioner johansson was in egypt
and i would like to thank all three of
them for their successful work and
tireless work we already see the impact
on the ground
we see that several airlines and civil
aviation authorities
have stopped unwarranted travel to
belarus
furthermore iraq has begun repatriating
national stand national stranded in
belarus
we very much welcome this very good
cooperation with iraq
but more migrants are trapped and we
will work with the un agencies to
facilitate their return home
we will mobilize up to 3.5 million euros
to support voluntary returns to belarus
and our efforts and this outreach will
continue
the strategies
frontier
ensemble
honorable members
member states facing such a hybrid
attack
must be able
to respond effectively
to the emergency situation they face
at the same time
they need to fully respect fundamental
rights and international obligations
both points are crucial
and we need to find a way to reconcile
them
we are therefore working on a proposal
for provisional emergency measures
in the area of asylum and return
based on article 78 3 of the treaty
the aim is
to support member states
to set up the right processes
to manage irregular arrivals in a swift
and orderly way
in line with fundamental rights
honourable members
last but not least
what is happening at the border with
belarus belongs to a broader context
recent actions by the lukashenko regime
and its supporters
are a determined attempt
to create a continuing and protracted
crisis
let me repeat
the european union does not recognize
this regime which violently represses
its own people
these actions are part of a concerted
effort
to destabilize the european union and
our neighborhood
this includes ukraine and moldova in
particular
these actions represent a real and
present danger to our union security
these actions go beyond
belarus
they are testing our resolve and unity
but
the european union has the will the
unity
and the resolve to face this and future
crisis
and with your support honorable members
we will withstand the test
and this is why today
more than ever i say long live europe
thank you
grazie president